le jardinage et le deuxième loisirs
préférés des français après les plaisirs
de la table alors si vous avez l'esprit
curieux et si vous voulez arpenter des
jarres base inattendu débute ce samedi
et jusqu'au 30 septembre
l'opération parole de jardiniers 46
participants des serres du château de
versailles aux sites de particuliers
comme celui donc de faux et guyancourt
où le jardin chinois de guily à
saint-rémy l'honorer visite conseil
échanges sont au programme ce mercredi
soir avec la soirée inaugurale dans les
jardins du petit trianon à versailles
l'occasion d'apprendre que les jardins
ont toujours existé 2000 ans avant
jésus-christ qui s'était d'abord
l'expression du pouvoir avant de devenir
un lieu de philosophie et lors de cette
visite nous avons demandé à deux
éminents amoureux des jardins quel était
le jardin de leurs rêves
alors le jardin de mes rêves c'est celui
qui est au bout du jardin parce que le
principe du jardin romantique c'est que
tous vous permet d'accéder par les yeux
un endroit plus loin où est le bonheur
et c'est ça le jardin romantique c'est
que le bonheur qui toujours un peuple et
loi moi j'arrête mon rêve il n'existe
plus jeune mon rêve c'était déjà mon
grand père
j'avais un grand père qui était un homme
délicieux qui cultivaient des légumes
cultivés au garde-à-vous des poireaux
qui paraît-il avait un goût de noisette
c'était vraiment le jardin qui était le
jardin de mon enfance et malheureusement
mon grand père a disparu et avec lui son
jardin donc le jardin de mon rêve c'est
un peu le jardin du grand-père de la
même union en province un jardin qui est
sans prétention qui est beau qui est
bien et que l'on quitte à regret les
jardins j'ai envie de dire personnel
la marathon il ya quelques fleurs mais
y'a pas grand chose car j'ai la chance
d'en avoir un dans le parc il y à une
pelouse il ya une chaise longue
il y à un parasol car je déteste traités
sous le soleil et il n'y a surtout pas
de fleurs parce que les gens là pour moi
c'est du repos
avec ça